Hello.
Hello, are you Muslim?
Yes, I am. Salaam Alaikum.
Yes, so what's what's what's what's the
deal?
Yeah, so did you just did you just tune
in or have you been listening to the
whole thing?
>> him or I can't hear him?
No, I I just tuned in.
You can't hear him? Hang on a sec. I
can't hear a single word he's saying,
man.
Hang on a sec.
Let me see if the audience can hear.
>> [snorts]
>> Can you hear him now? So say something.
Hello. Habibi. Yeah, now I can hear you.
Okay.
Yeah, as a go.
>> Yeah, go ahead. Did you just tune in?
Yeah, I just tuned in.
Okay, so Sam, one more time, run through
the argument and then let him respond.
Okay.
I just showed from the Quran the Holy
Spirit is a divine person uncreated. So,
according to who the Holy Spirit is
according to the Quran?
Uh I think usually we say Jibril.
You think what?
Jibril.
>> say Jibril, Jibril. Angel Gabriel. Do
you believe it? Do you believe that
though?
I mean, it's it's it's something that's
vague, yeah. I don't I don't think it's
important for the belief, but usually
say it's Gabriel, yeah. No, but it is
important because if the spirit is not
Gabriel and he's
creator
and he is life giver and he's uncreated,
that means you have more than one person
who's God.
Who said he's the creator? You're
confusing me right now. What What would
you say
he's the creator?
>> Quran says it is the creator. No, let me
show you.
Your Quran says it. Right here. Yeah,
I'll get there. I I promise you I'll
read it for you here. Surah Maryam, if
you want to read in Arabic, you can open
up your Arabic I'll read in English.
Surah Maryam, okay?
Okay, which verse?
We're going to read from ayat 16 to 21,
okay? I'm going to read it slowly, but I
want you to pay attention to 17
and 19, okay?
No problem. You read in Arabic. And make
mention of Mary in the scripture.
Okay, just give me 1 second. Let Let me
also You said
chapter 16, right?
>> chapter 19, Surah Maryam.
Chapter 19.
Surah Maryam, no problem. I'll I'll also
pull it up in Arabic, please. Yes.
I I will. I will. Yeah.
Okay. You are Muslim.
Yes, I am a Muslim. Surah Maryam, yeah.
Yeah, but you are Muslim, though.
Yes, of course. Alhamdulillah.
So, what you were saying, alhamdulillah,
you said?
Alhamdulillah.
You said audhubillah. You are not a
Muslim.
I said I said alhamdulillah, not
audhubillah. My religion So much for
pretending to be Muslim.
>> Why would I pretend to be Muslim? Let's
have manners.
>> There are people who do that just to
talk, but I trust you. But, go go ahead.
You got it up?
>> No problem.
Okay, so you said
verse
verse 15.
>> Maryam, we're going to read from ayat 16
to 21. Okay, I'm going to read in
English, okay? You let me know when
you're ready.
Oh, I'm I'm ready, yeah.
>> Okay. Make mention of Mary
in the scripture when she had withdrawn
from her people to a chamber looking
east. And had chosen seclusion from
them. Then we sent to her our spirit.
What's the Arabic for our spirit?
Ruhana.
Ru- Ruhana Aywa fatamaththala laha
basharan sawiyya.
What is it?
Ilayha ruhana.
Ruhana because the word ruh I just want
everyone to hear it. It means spirit,
okay?
>> Our soul. Our soul. No, it doesn't say
soul. Soul is nafs.
Yeah, but ruhana ilayha ruhana
fatamaththala laha basharan sawiyya. Ruh
means spirit. Just like Don't debate me
now. Ruh means spirit. Nafs means soul.
>> So, continue. Continue. I'm I'm not
interrupting, please.
>> Then we sent unto her our spirit and it
assumed for her the likeness of a
perfect man. So appeared as a man to
her.
The the the spirit. Good. So far I love
you. You're being honest. May God bless
you and shine his face on you the
fullness of truth. She said, "Lo, I seek
refuge in the beneficent one from thee
if thou art God-fearing."
He said, "Now who's speaking to her?"
Allah.
You So Allah appeared to her as a man?
No, one second.
Okay, the the the the the spirit the
spirit. Good good cuz you just said
Allah became his own messenger.
Yeah, kafir. Yeah, yeah. Continue.
Continue. Continue.
He said, "I'm only a messenger of thy
Lord that I may bestow on thee a
faultless son." What does the word I
have mean?
I have
gift.
To give.
Who's going to give?
To give the here right now the the the
the the
the the spirit.
So the spirit is going to give her a
faultless son?
Yes, by Allah's command. Okay, so Allah
commanded the spirit to come and give
her Jesus. So is the spirit created
Jesus?
By the will of Allah, yes. He is the
tool.
You just admitted to you. So the spirit
created, right?
I mean the spirit the spirit No, the
spirit the creator is Allah.
The creator is Allah.
Let let let let let let
let let let let me let me let me
challenge you for a second. Hold on. Let
me make my point. It says that I am only
a messenger of the Lord to announce to
you that Allah will give you a son or I
will give you a faultless son.
No, it says I don't I don't understand.
Can Can you say that that last part
again?
Did it say what you wanted to say? Did
he say, "I am only a messenger Lord
to announce to you that Allah will give
you a faultless son" or does it say that
I may give you a faultless son?
It literally says
I am a messenger of your God of of of
your God and
so I can give you
Yes, another part. You didn't finish the
other part. Translate it slowly.
Uh so he said in the name of Allah Anna
Only I I am only a messenger. Good.
Finish the other part.
>> Of your God of your God. Of your God.
Leah
to yeah. Leah means to give
you
means an un-faulty son. To give who
gives?
The the spirit. Okay, so let's not
debate. You just said it again. The
spirit told her I came here to give you
a son. So he's the one creating Are you
trying to trap me or you're going to let
me talk? I mean I want to give me a
second talk. Go ahead Habibi.
Go ahead. Yes, okay. So I I think okay
this is this is what what I understand,
okay? So I'm just saying what I
understand.
We [snorts] can say that also
my you know all all of us here on chat
and in this video call our parents made
us. If if if we follow
the logic that you're saying so cuz my
mom and my dad they came together and
they brought they brought me. So this
this is how So if if you're going to
take that logic okay my my mom and dad
are creators.
No yeah, well you proved my point
because just like it wasn't Allah who
had sex with your mom
and got her pregnant.
So it isn't Allah who gave Mary Jesus
the spirit did. So your argument
backfired against you. So did Allah have
sex with your mom and get her pregnant?
Listen listen. Let's let's have manners.
What I'm trying to say is let's let's
have manners. I'm respecting myself. All
right buddy, stop telling me about
manners. This is talking about your
analogy. Don't play victim to your
analogy. Yeah, he's he's actually
responding he's actually responding to
you.
So did He's not He's not trying to be
gross.
Yeah. Okay.
Did he?
No, right?
>> uh what were you saying? Continue.
Continue. Sorry.
>> So you just proved my case. Just like
you just proved my case.
Just like it wasn't Allah, you want to
cut me off again, brother? 30 more
times. Go ahead.
And you will talk about manners.
Just like it wasn't Allah
that came down and slept with your
mother.
Your father's own will actually got your
mother pregnant. So in your analogy,
it's the spirit who actually got Mary
pregnant. So it didn't help your case.
So the spirit is the one who created
>> it didn't help my case? If the spirit
comes, which you don't know what the
spirit is made of, you don't know what
is the material or substance that makes
The spirit said, "I am a messenger of
God."
And then it went straight forward and
said, "I will I will I will create I
will I will create Jesus for you by the
will of God."
Thank you. You just admitted it.
I will create as in he's the tool. He's
the tool. Okay, You actually admitted
it, right?
So So So Gabriel Gabriel gave Prophet
Muhammad the Quran.
>> say the spirit is Gabriel?
One second. I'm just saying from what we
know. Gabriel gave Prophet Muhammad the
Quran. Does that mean that Gabriel
created the Quran? This is This is a
joke.
>> No, that actually proves my case again.
You're not listening.
Did Allah come down and deliver the
Quran to Gabriel? Or did I'm sorry. Did
Allah come down and get deliver the
Quran to Muhammad? Or was Gabriel the
one who gave the Quran to Muhammad? Who
actually gave Muhammad the Quran? Allah
or Gabriel?
Allah through Gabriel. This is what we
know.
>> Let's try it again. Did Allah come down
to give it?
Did Allah come down to give
Did Allah come down and give You can't
answer my question. You got to leave.
>> Make Jesus Make Jesus
Make Jesus with Mary himself.
>> going to leave. Let's try it again. I'm
using your analogy cuz you're talking
>> I answered your question. I think I
answered your
>> actually came down and gave the Quran to
Muhammad? Allah or Gabriel?
Gabriel. Gabriel.
>> So, you just made my case again. Just
like Allah sent Gabriel and Gabriel's
the one who gave him the Quran, Allah
sent the spirit and the spirit is the
one who actually created Jesus. So,
we're back to square one. Can we stop
playing the game?
Okay, now 66
of Tahrim.
Okay, continue. I I think you're playing
a game here. You're playing a game of
words. What to say 66 I don't think I
don't think you're being courteous. I
don't think you're being courteous.
Go to Surat Tahrim.
Okay, which Surat Yalla Surat Tahrim?
Okay. 66
Surat
Al-Tahrim
Yeah.
Chapter 66
Why are you so uptight, man? Just chill.
I'm so upset, brother. You can't I'm
going to go eat pizza.
Yes, actually chill. Okay, which version
do you want me to to
Go to Surat Tahrim. 66 Yes.
>> Get to the last ayah. The last ayah. The
last ayah, ayah 12.
Yes.
Okay.
Slowly, slowly. What's farjaha mean?
What's farj mean?
Farji like like her chastity or
Like I don't know how to say it in
English. I don't I don't know how to say
it in English, honestly.
I It's like farjaha like her her
you know
Her what?
Her private part? Her Yeah, her Yeah,
her
her private parts in the Okay, did you
hear now, Cameron? Before you move on,
hold on, brother. I did.
>> Did you see he's an honest Muslim? He
just admit to you the word farj means
her private part. Mhm.
Okay. So, read it slowly cuz you know
Arabic. Cuz you guys you heard it,
right? Now, I that's why I like you.
You're very honest. So, I want you to
read slowly again.
Wa Maryam ibnata Imran allati ahsanat
farjaha fanfakhna fihi min ruhina Okay,
slow down. Feehi.
He blew into feehi. What did he blow
into?
Oh, in that case her her her furj or
like you can say her uterus.
>> He blew into her private parts, right?
Yeah, uterus. Let's say uterus because
yeah,
it's going to be a baby, right? So, it's
uterus.
>> Okay, what did he blow into Mary? Into
Mary's uterus. From our spirit.
So, why did the spirit
to do what? What did the spirit do when
he entered Mary?
To create
Prophet Jesus. Prophet Isa, yeah. Okay,
okay, man. He just made my case. You
heard it, right?
Mhm. Okay,
doesn't the Quran say the same thing
about Adam though? Doesn't it say that
doesn't the Quran
>> Jesus. Forget about the topic of Jesus.
We're talking about the spirit. Everyone
just heard you, which I respect you for.
You just said to everyone with we're
hearing it's recorded.
Mary guarded her private part.
Allah blew into her private part. His
spirit. And you said that's because the
spirit went and created Jesus. So, the
second time you admitted the spirit
created Jesus in Mary.
So, That's what I'm talking about, but
this is the this is the topic of the
this is the topic of the discussion that
the creator here is the Holy Spirit.
Yes, because I'm showing you your Quran
points to more than one person who's
God. So, your tawhid is a lie.